[Music]
in wrong number news hey what's the
wrong number
submitted by Patong any more annoying
for you but they won't find me they have
this thing at the Filipino bakery called
the puto it's the funny stick a
professional driver is suing a
Bangladeshi actor for ruining his life
after his phone number is released in a
movie oh wait how could it ruin your
videos a fake it was a fake number
no alright [ __ ] it it's not that easy
there's never that easy
yeah Bangladesh is in India yeah yeah
I'm gonna see I'm becoming more and more
worldly everyday I think yeah I think so
yeah it's called Bangalore
it's a country yeah India it's a little
one in between India and Bhutan and
Myanmar yeah yeah don't get pissed if
you call them Indian you're gonna know
what Bangladeshi oh no I thought
somewhere Burma okay so Bangladeshi film
star named Shakib Khan what a dope name
[ __ ] yeah everybody with the Khan name
my last name was kind of thing that's
like Genghis Khan [ __ ]
Steve Khan [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] yeah don't
[ __ ] with Steve Khan see you in the
wrestling bracket they don't want to
wrestle yeah yeah yeah you got that
psycho order is calling [ __ ] yeah yeah
that Khan bladder this is off topic okay
yeah so this film star he's one of the
country's highest acclaimed actors can't
you can't choose yes he's being sued by
an auto rickshaw driver for using his
business phone number on screen and one
if we're out of rakshasa that's what
they called it auto rickshaw he's like a
uber on the feet buddy boy
what's the auto part of it it's probably
just like a little scooter attached to
it scooter question let me show you Oh
Beyonce oh okay oh that's called a
tuk-tuk huh it's called a tuk-tuk we're
in Thailand right yep yeah misses
different names in different okay so my
question is if that's his business phone
number wouldn't be he began about
pre-publication business public
promotions you'd think that right just
prank call his ass no so a lot of these
a lot of female fans of Shakib Khan is
he could leftover [ __ ] what's the big
deal well he has a girlfriend and it's
actually ruined his relationship so he's
saying that a lot of these fans keep
calling trying to find the actor like oh
is this the actors phone number and so
he was like no but he keeps answering
hoping like it change your number dumb
ass yeah and I agree cuz when I was
reading this I was like come on just
change your number but you saying that
he didn't want to change his number
because he has a lot of established
client I get that Jim like well then
just let them know that you're cheating
you're going no it's a [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] cuz my dad did that so
might so before cell phones and [ __ ] was
around his his calling card was just you
know like his phone number and we
haven't changed it like since I've been
around so to change it all of a sudden
he'd get all [ __ ] up and if you like
let's say he bought billboards or like
bus benches and you're just work
yesterday sure he didn't buy any bus
benches or anything like that for auto
rickshaw or maybe for khao kheow saddles
or like for him to see that it ruined my
relationship I don't buy that [ __ ] that
just means your relationships sucked and
she's jealous yeah he's saying that like
his phone kept going off you receive
over 500 calls from women seeking the
actor a day and that like his seeking
him no we're just it's it's over you
maybe he's getting too much bangla [ __ ]
they that like the phone's going off
that his girlfriend started suspecting
that he was cheating oh no not his
girlfriend sorry his wife oh he was true
yeah and so that didn't she watched the
movie herself I know that's what I was
thinking too you could just explain it
to her but I'd be so pissed at her dude
that's so [ __ ] dumb he says like he's
a newly married man with one daughter
and that the wife is thinking that he
was having an affair oh there's one
particularly desperate fan traveled
fight traveled 300 miles to go see him
after she tracked down the address with
the phone number [ __ ]
and then so once she showed up that's
when his wife believed like oh this is
your mistress but doesn't she put in two
together when she's like where someone's
home in love with him like who are you
bro so his wife is stupid yeah sounds
like it
okay I guess we don't really have the
full story here cuz I have the same
questions you have a cheater and he's
using this as an escape oh he might be
telling it if you aren't do go see him
you have to [ __ ] me first yep maybe
that's what he's saying I guarantee you
that's what he's doing I am the
gatekeeper now his wife left to go
statement at a family's house oh no
because she's convinced that he's having
an affair or what if he really is having
an affair and then he's using this as a
cover-up maybe yeah I mean I don't know
they are saying that the the actor
recited the phone number in his recent
films oh I feel like both of them are
kind of lacking a few brain cells
because for me won't even put that in
there change the [ __ ] number right
yeah there's a script supervisor I think
for me if like my relationship you know
and I have a daughter is now on the line
I'd be like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
change my [ __ ] number like I provide
dope services don't find me you know but
he's like no I gotta keep my number
that's why I American movies as long as
five five five five
what if what if his number is five five
five five five five five you know what I
mean
you ruined my life I said five five five
bye-bye
has the kind of number that's why he
didn't want to let it go he's like you
know how hard it is to get five five
five five five five so now he's
considering selling his family home
no he's willing to get rid of his house
when I change his phone number he's some
guy that serves everything that's
happening to him right I hope he gets
run over by his own rickshaw he's suing
the actor for five million tacos which
is about which is sixty thousand dollars
in damage female tacos oh gosh damn
so he's a cute it was left open that's
what it is sorry
look accusing the filmmakers of
financially damaging him I don't I was
trying to back you up but you're [ __ ]
idiot you're just trying to get a
paycheck and I hope you die come on well
get lawyer
[Laughter]
it's a fraudulent act to publicize a
personal number without permission so
then that was it an accident I I don't
have the actor side I don't know I'm
pretty sure it was like a lucky guess
like yeah the driver I'm assuming the
guy in the left is the why does the guy
on the right look like a character from
a freaking skit or something yeah it's
like a fake human being like his hair
like the Wardrobe like everything the
Wardrobe nineveh he's like his hair
doesn't even look real
how you gonna be like the ashes you're
like the a shiest dark guy with the
brightest [ __ ] clothes dude yeah dude
this yeah the left looks like an Indian
Brendan Fraser to you oh yeah maybe
maybe I'm Bangla Bangladesh there's some
very many cultures just like India
[ __ ] is this fools [ __ ] phone number
four thousand numbers - hey baby you
love my number five four four three two
six eight nine four eight nine two three
four six seven eight five six seven to
12 goddamn it dude homeboy has a polka
dot baby blue long sleeve shirt under a
t-shirt yeah cuz it's kind of cold what
kind of hot Oh
who wears a button-up under a t-shirt
does he handsome you think ladies which
one the dark sky both of them I would
not [ __ ] if you had to choose oh my god
so only two in the world you had to
choose one of them you have to choose
which one you can I see the picture do
you wanna do I like doing this step
which one would you [ __ ] wait what do I
get out of it though no but that's it
probably the other guy yeah I don't do
good with like like loose skin and [ __ ]
the other guy looks like he doesn't have
loose oh [ __ ] the guide the dark guy he
looks like a smooth ball I like the gun
why does he look Mexican all of a sudden
yeah he's better than the other class
there's nothing wrong with telling me to
choose me to the other you know I think
I choose this guy
just because of the fact that the other
guy looks way older let's come across on
yeah but what do you kiss it was part of
the deal
well then I have to kiss him but if
we're just talking my [ __ ] I'm not
kissing at all but he has more money so
but you're not getting any
you don't care about financial game
that's right
this guy looks like he pours whiskey all
his dick before puts it in Papa's cigar
[ __ ] pointless game is dignified and
that was like Drakkar Noir which one is
your choice I did so boom
this guy's a winner huh who would you
[ __ ] you mean it's what do you mean if
they had to do in my butt yeah yeah
would you would you poke both oh that's
not the hard part not the harm you would
take the smaller guy yeah this guy small
guy has the biggest dick no you you
[ __ ] picked that guy you'd poke his
hole yeah no yeah it just looks a little
cleaner but he looks hairier dude yeah
he look oh you know Babu Babu has a
[ __ ] hairy ass this guy this guy
they're smooth walls I told you yeah no
my answer he got he got nice luscious
laughs who the doctor guy the door guy
and it looks smooth yeah did you [ __ ]
about dark guy okay yeah yeah the dark
guy he's faded already okay would you if
you had a choice if you had a french
kissin makeup for 30 minutes or you have
him but doing it in your butt for like
three minutes which one kissing all the
way one is gonna be painful that guy
looks like it's a big-ass dick no but if
they put a squirt of KY jelly in your
bum nah dude my for one minute but it's
like pure penetration but IRA I rather
kiss all day 30 minute kiss or one
minute but okay what about this kissing
or like sword fighting with vas all
sword fighting up sort by Vaseline on
both penises where it's it's like you're
almost you know I'm saying where you can
come because of the friction the
friction but it's a one minute it's a
women it's or fight five minutes I'll
sort of fight all this until one person
comes no no no
so what music you feel someone calm no
you just up the ante dude so making out
for 30 minutes or until this no once
work I rather sword fight you would
swear I want to get it over because
that's too intimate right that's a
matter yeah yeah then you would like
taste is because you could do one of
these things
no no but with that it's eye contact all
the way you're changing the rules
changing can we just settle this you
gotta take your his foreskin and wrap it
around your dick each other our friends
kissing for an hour
that's like sex but I can do not know
cuz it's the foreskin over the head of
your penis yeah going like that that's
that's really but I can go like this and
pretend like it's not happening it's
it's too perfect bro portals to your
soul and dick skin is different than
like face skin you mean like you can
deny some [ __ ] happen cuz you're like
that skin is just not his skin and he's
gonna waste a quart of whiskey on you
did that okay but we're having him the
dark I in your body getting to control
with the condom on I pick docum you're
getting out of control here it keeps
changing my favorite this is actually my
favorites because you want it in here
you want it in Europe but you want
someone to agree with you right I don't
know that's probably the easy way to go
though right no well three minutes of
that you're like I'm done I'm dead get
off dude